I suppose neither of us is used to the
spotlight well it's not always so
flattering you seem to be doing all
right so far considering your last trip
to Capitol Hill I wouldn't think it'd be
particularly comfortable in this company
I'm not that alone makes me glad you I
hear mr. Romanov why you don't approve
of all this
yeah courts yes the politics not really
two people in arrow can get more done
than a hundred unless you need to move
that piano
Baba yeah mr. burrows came to chaka
please allow me to apologize for what
happened in Nigeria thank you thank you
for agreeing to all this I'm set here
that Captain Rogers would not be joining
us today yes so am i that is the future
calling such a pleasure
again dodo cassoulet Mukarram Gelineau
Kusa Musa can Galaga weak ready Daniel
when stolen condemned vibranium was used
to make a terrible weapon
we in Wakanda were forced to question
our legacy those men and women killed in
Nigeria were part of a goodwill mission
from a country too long in the shadows
we will not however let his fortune
drive us back we will fight to improve
the world we wish to join I am grateful
to the Avengers for supporting this
initiative makanda is proud to extend
his hand in peace
you
you